hello everybody hope they are good this
video is going to be a bit different
because I'm going to map out all my
levels uh and only for today but also
for the next weeks okay we're going to
go from the weekly time frame all the
way into the one hour time frame I think
that there is qu of confusion about what
the price might do next and of course I
don't have a crystal ball I don't know
what's what I do next but all I'm doing
here is to discuss my analysis my
opinions um maybe you find them
interesting or not maybe they play out
maybe they don't but this is what this
platform is for so um in general I see a
lot of confusion in Twitter on on
YouTube on Telegram and is that H I feel
like most people don't really know where
the main support and resistances are at
the moment so I think that uh this video
is going to cover that and of course
some ideas projections triggers for uh
day Traders and swing Traders so let's
start with the weekly time frame
in this time frame I only want to Mark a
very strong support in my opinion and if
that if I put my indicator here uh you
can see here had a very strong
Confluence between the weekly 50ma and
the liquidity pool the liquidity pool
has been partially retraced but um for
example weeks we can consider a week to
be filled once it reaches at least the
50% but with the liquidity pools in my
opinion it's a bit different okay it
needs to go to the 100% so yes this
liquidity pool is still open valid I
don't know how to say it and it can
still go to the 100% if that is the case
then we also have there the weekly 50
MAA now if you notice that's a very
important uh EMA in my opinion uh
because it marks the trend although it
has a bit of lack it tends to be a good
reference to know whether if we are in a
bull market or in a bare market so as
long as we are above the weekly
50ma things are looking good to the
upside and as long as we are below it
then it's not looking that good okay uh
for example here you can see that we had
a like up then we retrace to the weekly
F we tested that level as as support
little deviation there okay then happens
again here we lose the quickly 50ma and
what happens well that we start to test
it a resistance then there is a
deviation but we test it again at
resistance so then it says Okay that was
a deviation and it's going to go down
close down what happens here again
tested a resistance another drop here uh
that was almost a 30% drop I think
reclaim the weekly 50ma test it a
support another leg up while you come
here little deviation tested again a
support continuation to the upside and
now we're in a moment that it's possible
that we test again the quickly 50a okay
if that is the case then I think that is
way more likely that we tested that
support again but who knows if you start
to see that we lose this
level and with drop below the previous
low that is telling you that the trend
has changed and you probably know that
when we are at 48,000
47,000 then yes you can expect lower
prices but in my opinion that is less
that is less likely to happen most
likely that we start to test the weekly
50ma support maybe even a little
deviation go back above testing again a
support and continuation to the upside
that is um what I think is more likely
to happen okay if we go back to the
weekly 50ma it's not that far it's at
1,700 um I don't know if we want to get
there or not but all I want to say is
that if we get to that level uh that's
actually $2,000 below the previous low
if you actually continue dropping and we
go to
51,70412
now after taking you to the Daily time
frame so so you can see the the current
the structure and also the main
resistance okay so basically we've been
ranging here for more than 3 months
almost four months so yes almost pretty
much four months of ranging long time
and we're want to Mark right now the
range so you have here the range
SI let's get them there okay and then
you have the range lows in this area
Okay so range highs range lows and also
in here I'm going to mark this quite
strong
resistance okay that we've actually left
here an area without without hitting
okay and this empty area here you can
see that we didn't Ru this high so uh
this area between
51,800 and
53,800 that's a very interesting area
full of liquidity so we could still get
that okay now what it seems that has
happened is that we've broken out from
the range to the downside
okay and sometimes we can get
deviations sometimes a deviation can
look like this but deviations can also
look a bit vep that right so I wouldn't
consider this to be um continuation well
signaling continuation to the downside
just because we're here I don't imagine
that we're going to do this necessarily
this could still get a deviation but
what I have clear for sure is that
60,000 700 that is going to act as
resistance in principle because look at
this support support
support support come on if you get there
that's going to act a resistance so so I
don't consider opening any swing long
position until we reclaim this level
6,700 so as long as we don't get above
here then it's pointless to open any
swing Lo position because uh I mean this
difference between 57,000 and 60,000 you
could take it in my opinion more as a
day trader okay not as a swing long
swing long should be longer trade an my
opinion yes a range of $10,000 that's
worth it for swing Traders so as long as
we don't get back about
6,700 is not really for any swing Lo
positions right um that's the main thing
that I want to
say now let's talk about imbalances the
chart is full of imbalances
to be honest we are retracing
them quite well so um it's looking quite
organic I'm going say and if you guys
remember from the Bitcoin to date I
posted that 3 days ago today's Tuesday
and if you remember I was talking about
this week here CU I was telling you guys
this week was my main concern at the
moment and I marked the 50% level the
50% of the week has been filled which
means that uh this week there is no need
to get again to the 100% of the week as
long as we stay far away from the 50%
level and so far yes like if you h mark
the 50% level then it'll be somewhere
like here okay this level here that is
hang on sorry for the clicking this is
the 50% of the week Eco felt Almost
100% And so far we are moving away from
the area we are 2
above the area so now if price starts to
do something like this okay going back
to the 50% of the label and
consolidating here then that can signal
the next move is to fill the 100% of the
week here okay but as long as we keep
away from the 50% level and that's what
we're doing so far then price can bounce
and go to this resistance right so um
that main imbalance in the daily time
frame has been filled uh I must say that
and why is not working there and now
we're going to go into lower time frame
4 hours time frame in this time frame
what I see which is quite interesting in
my opinion is this potential value
pattern and I just posted this idea on
Twitter okay look at that which is quite
interesting and if we use indicator so I
want to Mark only the 50 ma let's show
like this okay and the liquidity pools
I'm not going to S them right now so
let's remove
them this is the 50 ma in the 4 hours
time frame as you can see it's acted
since we've been going down as as a very
strong resistance you can see here
resistance resistance resistance
resistance here deviation and then
resistance drop and since then we
haven't tested it again so why not the
only way that I would open a new long if
I already didn't open a long at the 50%
of the week is if we can reclaim this
level again okay and that is the 4our
50a so imagine this is the 4H hour 50 ma
let me change the
color what you want to say what you want
to see here is this okay okay a push
above it and then inad of continue going
going higher then you want to see a test
of support if you get this test of
support then okay then you have here
quite a safe
trade of maybe 3% move okay so let me
let me
check that's uh well between three and
4% move okay so yeah di for example an
idea of a trade again not for swing
Traders but for they Traders yes why not
and this structure so far can happen
also
another uh variable is to turn this
into a three tops
patteron okay but to be honest for the
timing I don't see that that's going to
happen because we're already on Tuesday
uh we're going to talk also now about
the about the CPI
but if you notice this projection here
what we're talking here
about is something maybe more like
this and this ret is we're marking it
for
Thursday okay that would mean I'm from
Thursday we could see a push up and in
my opinion that can only
happen if this plays out this W plays
out this leg up will play out only after
CPI data why well let me Mark let me let
me show you something that I typed for
the Bitcoin the update and is basically
this let make it
bigger we've had unemployment data
released on Friday 5 days ago and
increased again from 4% to 4.1% now this
adds pressure to the to the FED to C
rates or if they don't C rates to at
least announce a rate good for the next
fomc meeting which is in September now
the next fomc meeting is the 31st of
July the last day of the month and then
the in August we don't have any the next
one is in September CU I guess they go
on holiday now we have already a bit of
pressure on the FED to start cting rates
because when employment keeps going up
and that's a sign that that's screaming
for a rate C however the other very
strong economic data is the inflation
data that's CPI consumer price index
that comes out an next today is Tuesday
so basically in two days and in my
opinion if the CPI data comes lower than
expected or and lower than previous
previous was 3.3% now expecting they're
expecting 3.1% so if he comes 3 to 1% or
lower like
3% then guys T's adding a huge pressure
on the FED to go the 31st of July and
the 31st of July they have probably to
make one of these two the either to
could r that day which um they don't
seem very likely to or what I do think
that is more likely is that they say in
the next FC meeting it's very likely
that we could R in September and um
that's basically the word in the street
um I think it makes sense um what I'm
basically thinking guys and is that the
market tends to price in what is going
to happen next so I do believe that we
get a very good CPI data then all the
market participants they're going to
start thinking okay this theory of the
FED announcing red CS is going to happen
and that is basically going to trigger a
leg up okay and I'm not talking about
massive L up I'm look at this guys I'm
only talking about first this L up of 3
4% which is not that much towards this
resistance okay now if we manage to
reclaim this resistance
a support then yes we can continue going
up in fact there is a lot of
liquidations at 6 at
67,000 so uh that is basically what you
need to pay attention uh on Thursday in
my opinion that is uh I wouldn't say a
theory but it's a a potential scenario
okay so yes if we get a very good CPI
print then perhaps the market starts to
imagine what the FED might do next
because uh they're going to have to
start cutting rates if that's the case
and Market is going to price that in and
push price up okay so keep keep an eye
on this projection okay and on CPI data
now maybe that was a bit boring for you
talking about um economy and the stuff
but let's go now into the one hour time
frame let's get into the action one hour
time frame it's been a very volatile
week and and perhaps you don't notice
but this moves here look at this
we've got this move down then you got
this move up then again move down then
again move up at the end that's quite a
volatile week even without even noticing
so um the first thing that I want to
talk about is what let's let let me Mark
here the Asian session okay now guys
something interesting if you're using
the indicator uh there is around 600 700
people using the indicator changed the
the trading session's time so take note
of these times because otherwise the the
chart the the indicator doesn't Mark
them correctly the times so I Chang into
this and in the second version of the
indicator remember that we are right now
the first version this will be updated
by default okay so right now I'm playing
with this times Asia 1 minute past 12 to
1 minute 9 then London 1 minute 9 to 1
minute 3
and York 1 minute p 3 to 1 minute P 9
okay so uh copy these times if you're
using the indicator perhaps you find it
more useful so what I wanted to mention
here is this I've always told you
something guys never trust a pump during
the session and that is something that
continuously plays out all the time guys
all the time
and not sure why but I I mean I don't
even I'm not even trying to find an
explanation all I know is what I see in
the chart and what I see in the chart is
that whenever Asia pushes price up then
we get retrace within the next 24 hours
okay sometimes it's London sometimes
it's New York and sometimes it's even
easier again in the next session so uh
you can see this pum here during the
session now that point let me mar the WF
strategy guys WF strategy okay look
pretty fast 1 2 3 go there it is okay we
had a Weck here that we got
filled well I mean maybe they didn't got
filled by $5 but that's a bit of slipage
uh but anyway I'm not going to if it's
49% fill or 50% fill to me that's filled
no point keeping that week there so yeah
that we is been filled now then you see
that pump during the as session London
retraces that week it creates another
week here that is here the 50% of the
week let me change this to White that
week gets filled you can see there okay
then price continue pushing up Asia has
again today pushed priced up and so far
London is retracing that so I would
imagine that at least today we're going
to uh revisit the 1 hour 50a to retrace
the I pum there okay but you can notice
how everything
is balancing out they are fing all the
imbalances the only imbalance that have
notice here that they haven't really fed
is this week to the upside so why not
why couldn't something like this play
out drop again to the one or 15a retrace
partially at least that ASM pump the ASM
pums don't have to be 100% retrace
although most of the time it does but it
could just go as low as the one or 50 ma
retrace that partially and then
continuation towards that week there
okay and then you got yourself here how
much is this 2% 2% price difference yes
2% price difference you don't need more
for a day trader okay so that's an idea
that I'm keeping an eye on for today so
let's see how price reacts first if we
get to the one or50 May and then they
see the reaction but that's an idea that
I have in mind okay and and all I want
to show you guys is that all the
imbalances are getting retraced which is
something very positive going into
Thursday okay because I remind you again
Thursday CPI that theory well that idea
that I mentioned could play out okay
this W pattern
here look at
that but for that
again you know what you need you need to
get back above the 4our 15a once that's
the case you test it back as support
then yes you can open a long more happy
more comfortable into the $60,000 level
that is going to be a strong resistance
in my opinion okay so that is pretty
much everything that I want to mention
guys uh I think the video is going to be
quite long so I'm not going to show you
the liquidation hit Maps I'm going to
post them on X instead tonight so anyway
guys uh tell me what you think uh I hope
that video
is useful perhaps I also post a video
about the altcoin market or talking a
bit about from alins like Solana H I
don't know chaining you know the main Al
coins see see what they can do in the
next following weeks but anyway guys
today I just felt more like because I
saw qu of confusion in the internet I
just felt like you know posting a a
longer update a bit more complex um I
hope I didn't make you Bor but anyway
guys I'm going to wrap this up here
thank you so much for watching guys and
I'll see you soon